have you ever done pictures without
those islands no nope and i never will
that's my trademark and you know if i
take that away then it's not me and no
one's gonna want to look at me without
my trademark so i hold on to that even
if we soften them up no kept no you can
do anything you want but my eyelashes
stay right where they are
to go from
this young girl who thinks that makeup
will send you to hell but also gets so
giddy when she gets a tube of mascara to
where we see her at the end where her
face is tattooed
what is that journey praise god remember
god loves you i want to say that too
i wanted to look as much as i could like
her so i could also connect to a sense
of why so many people are drawn to her
because she was so uniquely who she was
just the physical cost of doing this
role is so tremendous because she is
encased in latex wigs
trusses pregnancy pads nails out to here
i don't even know how to describe what
it must feel like it's many hours every
day to create that effect that you're
looking at tammy faye it's been an
incredible process of discovery for the
hair and makeup as well as the
prosthetics team
jessica and i are playing characters
that are
known
not only real but people have a very
defined image of who they are so there
was a responsibility to capture an
essence and to make it our own
we go from the 1960s
all the way up into the 1990s so
throughout that process both of them
have three different prosthetic
milestones so up until the early 80s is
stage one jessica has two cheek pieces a
small chin blender and a little nose
lift that she wears all the way up into
the early 80s 1985 it switches to what
we call stage two which is full cheeks
full neck she also has a different chin
blender and a nose lip and an upper lip
with that and then the final stage is
1990s stage three full neck
aged cheeks different chin
different lip no nose and then she gets
a certain degree of aging and stipple
that's put around her eyes i don't know
that i could have done the character
without it i don't know how to separate
the two the prosthetics were hurt in
some aspect at first i was like really
concerned because i was like this feels
really hard and you don't feel like you
can connect as easily with the moment
you feel conscious that you're wearing a
mask but then you start to forget it and
it becomes a bit more second nature oh
man hey man jim andrews character is
also very complicated stage one is sort
of two cheek pieces that he wears up
until the early 80s
late 80s he switches to
age stipple around his eyes two
different cheek pieces and a lower neck
waddle
and then his final stage in the 1990s is
a full neck cheeks stipple heavily
around his eyes and he also gets a ball
paid you look at the results like bryson
who does the brilliant wigs and the
brilliant looks throughout the decades
it's gratifying because it looks amazing
people who have sown seed in the word of
god their stock is always up
not only do we have the prosthetic
element but there's a real beauty
element here and no matter what people
may think of tammy faye's style of
makeup it was her way of beautifying
herself linda had special lashes made
she had things to make my lips look
smaller because i have bigger lips than
tammy did so she would just do all of
these things that absolutely transformed
my face and transformed my look in a
very strong way for me what was lovely
was to look at her when she was younger
where she began
and how she moved into the makeup and we
wanted to see that progression so we see
the freshness and the hope in her more
youthful look
and as we progress all the colors for
her in terms of her wardrobe her makeup
even her nails everything got a bit
darker
linda got a lot of reference material i
knew that i was going to have at least
eight to ten wigs we have brown we have
platinum blonde then we had a dirty
blonde with roots
and actually one of the wigs i actually
used a frost and tip to make it exactly
like tammy fay
hi it's an incredible process of not
knowing if you're gonna get there and
then when you see it you're like oh my
god there there you are we did it you
know and so they've done unbelievable
job you look great
come on doesn't she look amazing right
i have really adored tammy faye as long
as i've been aware of her so when this
opportunity came up it was something
that you can imagine a costume designer
really wanted to get their hands on
mitchell has a love for tammy that i
share
and it was very clear from our first
conversation that we were on the same
path in telling the story mitchell
travers our costume designer has created
a story with the colors and the patterns
and as they progress the world starts to
get more chaotic the color palette for
the movie starts in a place that comes
very much of the earth it's pretty much
limited towards browns and creams as her
universe expands we start to see apricot
mint navy and then we break out to a
place by the 80s where we're getting
i call it the golden girls palette which
is mauve pink pale blues and then we get
into this sort of hyper 80s extreme
palette where we have shocking reds
blues every time someone's putting on
something in the morning it's their
first act of how they're feeling that
day or what they're trying to put out
front so it was like a psychology class
of like what was tammy feeling right now
or what would she want right now as
things were really great in her life she
was in a much more controlled palette
her shapes were actually much more
simple than people remember and then as
certain influences came into her life
and certain people had a bit more
control over parts of her life you see
that her personal control over her
clothing shifts so she starts to be
wildly expressive you get crazy
metallics you get sequins you get an
abundance of jewelry he created this
closet i mean there were over 100
there's probably 110 costumes or changes
that he created i love the exuberance i
love the fearlessness and for jessica
and i it's an amazing opportunity to see
some things on camera that we have sort
of forgotten about the late 80s and give
them some time in front of a camera
again at one point i said i feel like
this is something that she would love
and it makes me happy that we're showing
her this way hi everybody she was always
there and mitchell made sure that she
was always in some weird way she was
part of the decision-making yeah i won't
go forward
looking in the rear-view mirror
of my life
i get to be a better makeup artist
because of the nature of the work and
always changing and always moving with
it and always
looking really deeply at a character and
how can i help facilitate
these wonderful actors work by giving
additional tools to bring that character
to life well hello there jamie hi there
the hair wigs beauty makeup and the rate
fashion moments really work together
along with the special effects makeup
knowing that it's exactly what andrew
and jessica needed to create this world
for them nice to see you hi how are you
for me this always had to come from a
place of honesty i do think that the
story is told in an honest way it's in
tribute to so it's not an exact match of
course we're trying to find things that
take the spirit of what they did and
make them in a way that fits into the
language that our film has created we're
live in 15 minutes okay
the recreation of jim and tammy was a
feat unto itself it's really a daunting
task and they did an incredible job
that's not what you have in stuff it's
people that count
amen
amen
i really wanted to make something that's
seamless not be a distraction you know
when you look at these characters it
should be
completely flawless and it shouldn't
look foreign by any means and i think
we've achieved that well i don't pretend
to be something i'm not because what you
see is all you get i've never met anyone
quite like you tammy faye
it's just an incredible job that
everyone's working in is really
impressive and it's so brilliant it's an
amazing group of people if god loves you
he really really does everyone shows the
specificity of things that are
technically very very difficult there's
no way with the amount of prep that we
had that anyone else could have
accomplished this
[Applause]
you